good morning max and happy birthday  please rate it on a scale from one to  ten five max  [Music]  Kelly shall be a cadet with you my  mechanic who betray you so sickly this  video looks at Singapore that demanded  that  [Music]  my name is a latina sir I hereby  confirmed that I and with assistance of  this hotel have decided to take my life  I think your neck baby is not assessor  girls illness will dilemma your request  has now been approved your decision can  no longer be canceled itself what we  were supposed to talk about earlier  maybe not the future  circle of life is our most popular  burial we're not allowed to be here  it's awful I really need to see that  again  it's not an option Maps  clock's ticking  you can go you can't escape  you  you